皆さん
クルトガしていますか
これです
アールズあげるって知ってますかん
えっ
これです
すごいよねくるとかって書いてるとつ駆逐して常に尖っている
アルファわけでもこう柔らかくて腕が疲れない
その2つの機能を備えたシャーペンがある方がれる
苦労が問わない対空
僕は後方の時
サーフィンにはまりましたん
山田辰よ本当にもうこの子世代だけで60本ぐらいサーペン買いましたもを好きで好き
でサーフィンが好きでサーフィンが猛勉強の何か良い
原動力になってて
何かを関税が言ってた色々とサテンでなんか頭の良さが決まると思ってて
もうこれコロコロ黒サーフィン変えてましたね
あんまりサーフィンなんてどれでもいいと思ってる人いるんですけどちょっと気にして
みてはいかがでしょうがこの際
くる所がいいと思います書いてずっとトゲトゲしてるか
けど
goot がはん
回全部疲れませんかいうん
そういうのをなくしたのが
こちらのシャーペンです知ってる人は知ってると思うんですけど
ぜひ受験生の方にお勧めしくっ
ん
大
このスタイルやばいそしてこのぷにぷにした
落ちてちょっと書いてみましょう
僕は今伊蔵これ使ってますレウスてる人いると思うんですけど
が来たーーグリップです
店なった
こんな数だった
スラスラってくれます
けど叶われ下げるすごいんすよ本当に
ん
まず見た目のかっこいい本当にすごいキラキラ捨てて
パーかけやすいですね
強い書きやすいでも探せが描けます
かつ野菜ですね
他のホロこの方のコロコロ国会でたら
回転してるんですよこれ
つまり
この子がずっとねー
耳が丸まらないんですよ常に行こう
なんか常に同じ字の太さでかけるっていうねすごいんですよ
勉強しなきゃいけないのにやる気が出ないっていうと使うものから帰ってみたらどうす
か
本当にならん
かっこいい各いっていうかこれやばいマジで本当に書きやすいんじゃ
バッハ